and with the new wave of coronavirus  cases health officials  urging people to get the flu shot the  health district in partnership with  roseman university hosted a flu shot  clinic earlier today  anyone 19 and older was able to get the  vaccine for free  it's extremely important to make sure  that you get vaccinated against  influenza this year because we want to  avoid  the concept of what we call a twin  pandemic where we have both cova 19 and  influenza cases unfortunately inundating  our health care system and that's really  what we're trying to avoid  for more information about future  immunization events you can visit the  website immunizednevada.org  just click on their community calendar